we're going to rap lyrics were in
Atlanta I mean come on it's the Dirty
South alright stacks on deck patron on
ice we can pop bottles all night you can
have whatever you love no where'd you
get that platinum chain with them
diamond and that was last year
with Chris Sims and Stephane dick
Stephane back again great to see is
always looking good great season for you
and the Vikings and I'm not rapping for
you today how you feeling season over
body gets a chance to recover a couple
weeks removed house we've been talking
to guys about that cuz this talk about
the 17 game season how you feel after
getting 16 plus a couple playoff games
since I've been in a league this is my
healthiest year I'll walk out without a
scratch right no but since then in the
past it does get rough and you need like
two to three weeks maybe even a month or
two just to really kind of feel back to
being yourself so I was lucky enough to
come out without a scratch and you know
I'm thankful for that was my healthiest
season hey you're a baller you're the
man you're one of the best in the game
it was a crazy year though like kind of
started out slow for you feelin calls
out cousins right interesting do you it
wasn't I want to know your take there do
you think that changed the Ottomans Kirk
Cousins what was your take on that like
the first number first couple of weeks
was rough right now I have you know I'm
I'm always been honest and transparent
and professional as possible and those
first couple weeks ago at one game we
threw the ball nine times out of ten
times right and as a receiver as much as
you love that you want to win at the end
of the day but you also want to be
utilized and that's anybody at any
position any any job you know no matter
what I am you want to be used to you
lost to the best of your ability and of
course we want to throw the ball like
that but we were winning so you kind of
keep it all in perspective yeah we're
still winning but throw that later on I
think we played Chicago or somebody and
we tried to throw the ball and you know
we kind of got down early we had a and
turnovers and you try to throw it by
Warren having a lot of success yeah and
it was a test to say we have him in
throw on the ball so it's kind of hard
to come out there and kind of roll the
dice and say alright let's throw it now
exactly so I feel like with that
conversation you know with with what
Adam said
and we faced a lot of scrutiny in the
beginning and at one point date they
built a narrative around me and I didn't
never I didn't ever say anything
actually you know but that's how it goes
you know as you as a receiver that
everybody assumes diva you want the ball
at XYZ but we wanted to win and we knew
we knew we needed to have a healthy
balance to win the game so it kind of
kind of got rolling up to that point
yeah and then after that point things
kind of took off you know the narrative
for the Vikings is the passing game
we'll be there if the running game is
there and if the running games not then
it's harder to pass how do you try to
flip that is there an effort to flip
that so you don't need to have the
running game going to have the passing
game the passing game can stand on its
own you know in our minds you know of
course you want all wheels turning at
all times you know and the Year previous
that we were heavy on the past we didn't
run enough yeah right right and then
this year we're having on a run and
somehow I feel like we we didn't pass
enough but to have that healthy balance
it's just hard to say cuz it's
whatever's gonna win you to week
you know there's winter ball right where
the times gonna win that's what you got
to do but if it's passing if it's
running the ball at a hot level it's
just whatever you got to do to win it
for us it's kind of always hard to gauge
that healthy balance of doing both you
see you see some teams do it but for us
to just kind of art you know you got two
receivers exceptional receivers yes you
got a great running back right you got a
quarterback that can throw the ball you
got tight ends that can block and catch
pass catch so it's just a hard spot to
be here are you guys shocked to like
just the constant criticism or like
microscope that's on Kirk Cousins in the
locker room oh no cuz you know at this
one we're kind of used to our you know
good or bad if he does good every was
like okay but if he does bad you're
gonna blow it up every time but for us
consistently he's been the same person
you know you can expect the same guy
from him that work each and every day
and in game time you know it's not
people love to blame the quarterback I
know it's a lot of things that need to
go well for the quarterback you know
have success as well you know but for us
I just always feel like as a quarterback
you make the big bucks they always gonna
blame you but as you as his teammate and
as a receiver I'm always supportive no
matter what does the playoff wind carry
over to next year the fact that he
delivered in overtime even though the
next week didn't go the way you guys
wanted how much of that that over that
overtime win and everything about that
going into New Orleans I went does that
propel into 2020 you you wanna you want
to always hope for that you know but at
the same time it's going to be a new
it's gonna be a new lead gear and it's
gonna be everybody has an equal
opportunity meeting again so you you
want to say that yeah hopefully you know
it would take off wherever you left off
right right but I didn't realistically
and this time and you know 2020 you
gonna look at a new year and everybody
just got to get back on the ground
really cuz at this point our season's
over
you know we're rootin for some ideas at
this point to uh bring it home but you
know I hope so
all right it's awesome cuz you play both
these teams in the Superbowl like give
me your you know give me your two
sentence breakdown on what jumped out to
you about both football teams you got to
play Kansas City without my home so you
didn't write you know it's different um
that seems a differencing whim is ran
through hemming yeah that extremely high
level all the time yeah so it's kind of
like when he's not there they kind of
gotta figure it out and their defense
held their own when we played them they
play they play good run deep that's what
we want to do we wanted to burn the ball
and stop the run and we had to figure
some stuff out so for us I feel like my
two cents break down it's gonna come
down to defense you know it's gonna come
down to deviance cuz there's two defense
I feel like the cheese player a lot of
swag they played with a lot of you know
they play with that a lot of effort and
everybody's on but that's that San
Francisco defense that Dean line it /
alright Lee yeah personally I know they
got a heck of an edge rushes you know
they're coming off the edge d4 its back
playing at a high level and they got
some it got some underrated linebackers
right and even those interior guys Eric
Eric are my words buster yeah they're
tree trunk is they're underrated in the
inside and not feel like Pat mahomes
can't escape the pocket he can throw it
ball extremely well but it's all come
down to Tom yes somehow I think
somebody's going to get home not
something I take somebody gonna get home
yes when I watch them out watch them on
tape right it's special yeah right right
well throughout the course of the season
we had plenty of Stefon Diggs highlights
check it out the monitor we got it's a
Vikings highlights oh baby
this is the Philadelphia Eagles we call
this God and because
a year before that was that's right that
was the sunday game in Philadelphia this
was a night game where NFL football
games to this game I fumbled earlier oh
you did you fumbled early man you're hey
you're one of the better route runners
in all of football I know you take pride
in it
Thanks being out these Byron Jones look
at that cushion and you still run by him
that's that no that was that comeback
that was the moment when things started
to go the right way yep twenty20 and
Florio jumped on the Kirk Cousins back
tomorrow
good good please do feel free to choose
the guy you saw both the 49ers and the
Chiefs who's the guy that you would be
looking out the corner of your eye at to
make sure you get away from him if he's
coming your way on either defense um let
me see
hitting one yeah Kansas City Tom
Matthews surveying a fish yeah right he
can play the whole field I'm talking
about sideline to sideline yeah run game
pass game any smart yeah smart and
instinctive he's everything you want in
the safety you know but as far as like
hard hitting on the on Kansas City yeah
who is that guy I mean anybody hit you
are they catch you you know I didn't
today but I play receiver so I ain't
really in the trenches you have that's a
better question foot don't be like the
49ers though if you ran a slant route a
little against them because of their
linebackers are you talking about you
were wearing little worried there's a
key so I
if I'm picking in my mom in my heart
yeah please don't mean Francisco's
defense is they show up they winning
game yeah because I feel like it passing
my home even though they can come come
from behind and play if they get up
early that defense gonna fly
well that's we've been talking about me
the Chiefs fell behind the Texas they
fell behind the Titans but this 49ers if
their team I feel like that San
Francisco defense is differ from the
Texans defense yeah you know at the end
of the day techs are great football team
right now I'm not gonna say the defense
is bad sure but they're not as good as
San Francisco and they're not gonna be
able to play from what you got we got
something else for you we got a little
face mashup from some of your teammates
let's let's see if you can tell who
these are these are two teammates
no it's what it is one and who's the
other one it's not a thing name you can
focus on the eyes it's not a player in
your organization though could be a code
it would be old enough to have bag under
his eyes looks like og its Zimmer I
don't see them I see Phil Jackson right
there that's Phil Jackson with spikes
neck it's Diggs and Alvin yeah let's see
the last one is it looks terrible that's
cousins and that's your nose my hair
that's about it Genesis you know I'm
here on behalf of Genesis that's why I'm
hanging out with you great fellas yeah
we are actually
you guys are okay yeah Fischer luxury
car but NFL as well you know so you ever
guys ever need to make beat me to make
some phone calls I'll let you know okay
um I've been chauffeured in the g90 yeah
you know my first time having a
chauffeur as well so I feel so big-time
somewhat important right you know it's a
good day and they have a huge unveiling
tonight you gotta tune in for the
surprise I'll be a part of that so you
followed me where do they tune in where
do they to
to see the surprise you can watch a my
Instagram you watch the Genesis
Instagram so it's gonna be a huge
unveiling so it's gonna be a big deal
yeah I uh I haven't yet to be in one a
Genesis car I mean I've seen them lately
I've seen some commercials and things
like that but yet to do it so you're in
the g90 today yeah I'm in a 90 day I'll
make some phone calls to see if we can
get you put okay just cuz you're mark I
mean that sounds like it sounds like an
awesome car I mean g9t is luxury
yeah luxury and you're sitting in the
backseat with the guy driving you around
today drinking water and the rich get
richer get your game pick and your MVP
for the Super Bowl oh you ready I cap
big to tow can I at least speak to -
what sorry two teams yeah but listen no
it's gonna be two-sided if Kansas City
wins gonna be yeah okay we know that
right but if San Francisco wins
surprisingly is gonna surprise you yeah
they want to lean toward that deepens I
think the demon is gonna do a great job
but I think Jimmy T's going winning
Jimmy Jesus I get it yeah I'm with you I
think there's a chance - all right now
who wins again he's saying he's leaning
in San Francisco told the senator skoe
and I think Jimmy G cuz everybody said
like oh he didn't throw the ball that
much less right I feel like they're
gonna run the ball extremely well and
Shannon's won't draw it up yeah I love
the way he calls the plays but all his
face seemed to work you know he puts
everybody in position way towards kid
who's gonna do his job right Ron block
he's gonna catch the ball but I think
they gonna make Jimmy G win I think
they're gonna try to stop the run yeah
yeah what's the fun this is three
straight years we've had you next year I
hope we don't you know I'm trying to
play because you will be unavailable
you'll be practice but not next year not
next city yeah
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports